I think that in Brussels they do want to
reach a deal with the UK over brexit but
it has to be a deal that corresponds
somehow to the to the rules and
structures and ways of operating that
the EU has for its other 27 members and
the problem for missus may in my view is
that what checkers has done has in a
sense taken over taken her across a sort
of Rubicon I think she's deserted her
previous approach she wants to find a
new approach to the brexit negotiation
and she has crossed the Rubicon but
leaving a very very large number of Tory
enemies behind I read lies and she said
she still got her red lines but of
course we're not so sure that she has
but here's the problem she hasn't yet
found the means to arrive at her new
destination now that she's on the other
side of the bank and and and there she
comes
you know absolutely you know clean over
what needs to be done the compromises
that need to be made if as she as she
seems to want to do to put the interests
of the economy and jobs ahead of
sovereignty unless she comes clean I
don't think she will repair the enormous
tan she's got to admit that actually
well we won't be taking back control we
won't be sovereign well so much as
obvious look we are light years away
from what people expected all were
promised at the time of the referendum
the whole negotiation over the last two
years has been a complete shambles not
surprisingly people are disillusioned
and that disillusionment for many is now
turning to anger and far from you know
reuniting the country the divisions
within the government and the cabinet
within the parties between the parties
and in the country as a whole those
divisions are as great as any and in my
view the only way forward for mrs. may
is to continue the negotiation and put
the best deal that she can find to all
people to or to the people's vote
because I think that
the only way to give legitimate a
democratic legitimacy to the final deal
and to and to get approval from the
public is to put it to such of those so
you think she will get a deal I I think
it's right I can still put it to the
people
III think that people now want to make
an informed judgment and choice between
what is on offer as a result of this in
negotiation and the benefits we already
have in the European Union but also I
think that if she promises a peoples
about it will strengthen her hand
against the Brecht streamis in her own
apartment him and say look what I
negotiate has got to pass muster it's
got to gain the support of the British
people so untie my hands let me
negotiate properly because you're going
to face a public vote at the end of the
day and unless you can say that to them
they're going to continue this is
typical European wriggling it's what
they did to the Irish you know hold a
referendum get a result don't like it
hold another one no it's completely
different we are having a negotiation
well why is it different I mean we are
holding a negotiation and we have got to
come up with the best possible means of
Britain of of bringing about
implementing the original reference
because that's the instruction that was
given to the British government
but the problem Adam is this that what
we are seeing emerging from this
negotiation is so completely different
from what people expected in the first
place they were told they would have the
exact same trade benefits as a result of
leaving the European Union they said
that magical global trade deals would
appear all over the world we were told
that 350 million pounds extra for the
National Health Service would appear as
a result of brexit we were told there'd
be no big money for there was he knows
but not as a result of brexit and we
were told that there would be no large
sums of money being parceled over to the
European Union gained and that promise
has also already been broke
so people's disillusionment I think has
sparked this shift in the polls that's
men giving us a bad deal you what you've
got to do is to sell staying in
something which is seventeen point four
million people what the European Union
doing are giving us offering us the very
best deal that they can which the
British government has already reject
you hadn't I mean let's be you know
let's be very clear about this reality
let's be very clear the European Union
has said you Britain can leave the
European Union but stay within the
economic structures of the European
Union and in a sense have the best of
both worlds that has been rejected by
the British government and that sort
marks them out from the opposition
Labour Party who was saying yes leave
the European Union but stay in a customs
union and get a full participation in
the single market now until the does
that freedom of movement of European
people into this country and accept that
there has to be a managed fair freedom
of movement or of people where public
opinion by the way is much more nuanced
than you know than many suggest well
what the opinion polls show is very
interesting
there's been another shift in opinion
from people who were saying well
actually I would prioritize staying in
the single market over freedom of
movement they are more nuanced in the
sense that they understand why we need
skilled and talented workers we want
people who are going to work properly
pay their taxes and be committed to this
country we want students and graduates
we want seasonal workers what what
people are concerned about a demand this
is very important is that unskilled
people are coming here and settling here
without jobs and are potentially
undercutting the terms and conditions of
existing workers it's that that we've
got to guard against and take action
against not ruling out we certainly can
within the existing rules so you've been
involved with many campaigns over the
years rise of new labor in your heart of
hearts do you think this is really going
to be reverse that Britain's going to
stay in the European
what's important for me is the principle
of giving people a vote in my view the
only way we're going to give democratic
legitimacy in approval to the final deal
is that is if the people themselves can
sign off on it that's what's got to
happen and I think that mrs. May will be
greatly assisted in dealing with her own
party if they know that that public
sanction that backstop is in place at
the end of the day people have got to be
able to make an informed choice in other
words and judgement between the best
negotiation misses may can produce and
the benefits we have existing in our
membership of the European Union no one
else and thank you very much indeed